think this is not your mama's wrong from
here so what about the premise were you
like oh this is totally appealing to me
yeah I think that's what I loved about
it yeah
Zach got Pete dressed up for the acacia
he has not razzled
I'm really glad you dressed up for
tonight
you know what it was there was something
about it it was like not just romantic
comedy and not just a time travel film
it was all the things and it is such a
sweet fun way you know and it's a
chemistry with this I mean I don't know
who he's so funny that all we did was
laugh laugh laugh laugh so it was it was
pretty cool so do you get now that
you've worked opposite of him do you get
why he's so Charming to so many honestly
he's just he's just a really sweet human
being there was especially shooting here
in New York he has a lot of fans and I
mean mobs of people as we were shooting
and the guy stops for every single
person he takes a photo with every
person he signs every autograph he's
really generous when it comes to that
and it's a really sweet side of him well
you're the real deal too and you are the
sweetest but the movie is called me here
it's very cute what was your meet cute
moment with your boyfriend Tom you know
we met actually it's a very Hollywood
Story we have the same manager oh I know
so we met at the Ozark Premiere I was
actually a guest of my managers and I
went with her was it this one this
well I wasn't exactly on the carpet yeah
no I went inside I was so excited I just
went with my manager and we met there
and it was love at first sight bro I say
bye yeah I know he's the cutest of all I
have got to come clean with you
I'm from London Church
I am I'm sorry I'm a little confused if
you could time travel you like your
character like Sheila in the movie where
would you go and why I just I don't like
this whole time travel thing I want to
play it too messy yeah it messes with
time messes with what's supposed to
naturally happen right I prefer just
playing it in a film
[Music]